so in this some video we're going to
show you how to do this with the massage
tool I like using the longer one right
here we're going to take the belly
button we're going to go over an inch
and an inch down and you're going to
hold this straight down and press it
straight down the reason I like the
massage tool is we can get a lot more
pressure going down with a very little
pressure on the on the handle but you
can feel a little tenderness so we go we
kind of rock it to the left and right
and find that spot there and then we
wait and we just go up a half an inch
and work on that again you do this
before you go to bed about about I'd say
two or three minutes we're going to
start going up this spending about a
half a about a half a minute on one
point but here's the thing you're going
to find that there are certain points
that are really really tender that you
might spend two minutes on or longer but
you just want to keep working it out go
to your tolerance of pain
okay this way here we're just kind of
coming up an inch at a time and then
finally right underneath your rib cage
right there
good now let's take the belly button
let's see the belly buttons right here
we'll come on an inch off that side and
down straight down right through here
right down here and it comes yeah you
feel that we're going to come up 30
seconds later just hold that right there
come up this way 30 seconds
and a little bit more
one last point again I'm just rapidly
going through this but you're going to
hold 30 seconds right on that one point
make sure it's straight down yeah but
your neck is going to get loose after
you do this obviously don't do it if it
hurts if it's sore then do it less go
lighter everyone's different sometimes
there's people very sensitive some
people you press deep in there they
don't feel anything but the goal is to
keep doing it so this whole area relaxes
the thing is that the adrenals are
tucked way way inside there so you're
not really on the adrenals you're on the
soft tissue that's surrounding those
organs so we're just what we're doing is
we're just taking a lot of stress out of
the abdomen because if you think about
it
when you go through steps you feel a lot
of tension through the mid part right
through here and so you're actually
indirectly working on the adrenal
mechanism pulling stress out and then
Chinese medicine all the acupressure
points for the kidney and adrenal go
right up through up and down through
these points okay so that's how you do
it with the massage tool